[Musica]
[Applauso]
come se si fanno fotografare nel buco
nero che il trap rifinizione non può
essere fotografato il suo che
l'orizzonte degli eventi non puoi
mettere luce prima di spiegare come
questo sia stato fatto è necessario fare
un passo indietro
e spiega che cosa siano i buchi neri e
per spiegare cosa siano i buchi neri è
necessario introdurre la la teoria che
dà vita a questi oggetti
questa teoria viene da albert einstein e
nel 1915 introduce la sua teoria della
relatività generale
la teoria della gravitazione che andrà a
sostituire la teoria della gravità fino
allora usata che era quella di newton e
da una idea completamente rivoluzionaria
che cosa sia la gravità il succo di
questa teoria e quindi anche la
soluzione del buco nero è espressa da
queste equazioni persecuzioni sono
considerate tra le più belle nella
fisica matematica e sono anche
consigliato alle tra le più complesse da
risolvere e probabilmente a voi
sembreranno semplicemente un miscuglio
di di lettere e strane ecco questo è
giusto che sia così perché per
comprendere queste equazioni è
necessario aver studiato almeno tre anni
di fisica ed aver seguito un intercorso
alla cui fine io riesco a spiegare cosa
sono queste equazioni che nonostante è
possibile avere un'idea abbastanza
semplice di cosa vogliano dire se
guardiamo al simbolo che tutti quanti
conoscete in questa equazione ed il
simbolo di uguale bene il singolo di
uguale e tra due parti sulla parte
sinistra che è una misura della
curvatura dello spazio tempo e la parte
destra che è una misura della quantità
di massa che c'è nello nello spazio
tempo e quindi queste equazioni
semplicemente ci vengono a dire che c'è
un equivalenza e destra è uguale a
sinistra che curvatura è uguale a
materia materia uguale a curvatura
in altre parole ci dicono che ogni volta
che c'è materia c'è curvatura e se c'è
curvatura sei una superficie non è più
piatta ma in curva questo produce il
moto di oggetti che dovranno cadere
al centro di questa curvatura e per
questo che ad esempio se avete questa
immagine vedete che c'è un pianeta e
intorno ad esso c'è una una curvatura
allora se ogni oggetto materiale può
produrre una curvatura e se prodotta sia
da
un granello di sabbia che da un pianeta
e questo può sembrare strano ma in
realtà è proprio così
entrambi gli oggetti produca una
curvatura e quindi la differenza è solo
una questione di quanto è severa questa
curvatura facciamo un esempio prendiamo
il sole il sole a 700 mila chilometri di
raggio ma ci diamo dimostrare la
curvatura prodotta dal sole quello che
vedremo è qualcosa di questo genere
fondamentalmente non superficie che è
praticamente piatta infatti non ha
vediamo d'occhio nudo bisogno di avere
un colore per distinguere i diversi
gradi di curvatura
se però io prendo il sole e lo comprimo
in maniera idealizzata in un oggetto che
ha un raggio di soli 10 chilometri la
curvatura che verrebbe prodotta è questa
come vedete adesso è facile anche ad
occhio nudo vedere come la superficie
non sia più piatta ma sia attualmente a
curva bene continuiamo in questo
esperimento pensato e proviamo a
comprimere ancora ulteriormente il sole
ecco a questo punto non è più possibile
farlo avendo un oggetto è una superficie
solida ma credo che si produce un gruppo
nero quindi un buco nero altro non è se
non un oggetto che ha una massa
estremamente grande ma soprattutto in
uno spazio estremamente piccolo
estremamente compatto quando si crea un
buco nero vengono fuori due cose
importanti la prima è che si crei un
orizzonte degli eventi che in questa
rappresentazione due dimensioni è
rappresentata da un cerchio orientare
una superficie sferica bene all'interno
di questo di questo orizzonte degli
eventi è possibile soltanto entrare e
non uscire per questo che non è
possibile emettere luce dalla superficie
delle orizzonte degli eventi
un'altra importante caratteristica di un
buco nero che al suo centro le nostre
equazioni cessano di essere valide e c'è
una singolarità dello spazio tempo
adesso perché tutti questi concetti sono
così strani a noi questo è dovuto al
fatto che qui dove viviamo in questo in
questo teatro lo spazio tempo è
praticamente piatto e quindi noi siamo
più abituati a situazioni a sinistra che
la situazione a deaf ed è per questo che
tante delle cose che che hanno a che
fare con i buchi neri ci sembrano così
strano
però è possibile spiegare questi
attraverso la quella teoria che appunto
vi ho mostrato per sé i buchi neri
possono essere create su una questione
di comprimere materia in uno spazio
abbastanza piccolo andiamo a caccia di
buchi neri
il problema con i buchi neri è che sono
ha detto estremamente compatte quindi se
prendete un buco nero e lo mettete nel
cielo avrà un raggio di un chilometro
bene però se non mettete a distanza di
milioni di anni luce
diventerà un qualcosa di estremamente
piccolo no allora come si fa a fare uni
mario di l'oggetto che estremamente
piccolo ea raggiungere una risoluzione
estremamente alta il tipo di risoluzione
cesaria se volete avere un'idea è questa
prendete un chicco di riso lo mettete a
new york e dovrete cercare di vederlo
stando quindi ecco più o meno questo il
tipo di soluzione che necessario
non ti viene alta risoluzione in
astronomia in genere quello che si
chiama e che si costruisce un telescopio
grande perché più è grande il telescopio
è più in realtà la capacità di andare in
dettaglio la risoluzione appunto nel
caso di un buco nero loggetta così
piccolo che sarebbe necessario avere un
trasloco grandi quanto l'intero pianeta
è chiaramente questo non è fisicamente
possibile
o forse no e possibile e invece di avere
un unico telescopio io ho tanti
telescopi e le metto insieme in maniera
tale che stiano osservando esattamente
lo stesso fronte d'onda la stessa onda
elettromagnetica viene ricevuta ad
esempio un telescopio in arizona è un
telescopio alle hawaii
la distanza tra questi due telescopi e
circa 3.000 chilometri e quindi
virtualmente o un telescopio che è
grande e 3.000 chilometri
com'è possibile che questo avvenga bene
questo è possibile perché si fa usa
questa tecnica che si chiama
interferometria e che ci consente di
mettere insieme il segnale di due
telescopi un ingrediente essenziale in
questa ricetta è la sincronia
ed è per questo che tutti questi
telescopi in aggiunta area registrare
questo segnale elettrico riescono anche
a segnare il tempo esatto attraverso
degli orologi atomici di quando il
segnale arriva a questo punto non avete
soltanto una serie di segnali avete una
serie di segnali sincro ii e potete
mettere gli insiemi facendo
interferometria adesso la terra ruota e
questo è un po un problema perché sia
immaginate la sorgente a un certo punto
scomparirà e per questo che si usano
tanti telescopi perché facendo queste
triangolazioni queste interferometria è
possibile mettere insieme tanti
telescopi e questo è quello che è stato
fatto con questa collaborazione di
venturoni telescope
in particolare un gruppo europeo che è
stato ha diretto da me e dai miei
colleghi ad attori forti contributi a
questo sforzo
se vogliamo quello che è successo e
l'aprile 2017 quindi circa due anni fa
abbiamo mandato delle persone a fare
osservazioni in questi in questi diversi
radiotelescopi questa è un'immagine di
queste squadre e come potete vedere
tutte queste immagini hanno qualcosa in
comune
a parte il fatto che la gente è contenta
tutte queste persone questi posti anno
perfetto tempo perfetto e questo se
pensate un po un paradosso perché noi
cerchiamo riprendere luce che viene da
55 milioni di anni luce da noi e quindi
ha viaggiato per 55 milioni di anni e
poi sufficiente che c'è una nuvola a un
km sopra sopra il telescopio e non la
vediamo più perché la nuvola assorbirà
tutta questa luce ed è quindi la gente
era contenta perché non c'erano nuvole
quello che abbiamo fatto può essere
sintetizzato tra questa da questo da
questo animazione
fondamentalmente andiamo a venire
il centro e della considerazione della
vergine al 100 di questa osservazione
c'è il vicino a queste cose c'è un a
galla un ammasso di galassie c'è un
gruppo di galassie e al centro di questo
ammasso cene quella più massiccia che si
chiama m 87 e noi lo usiamo i telescopi
ottici vediamo che è possibile andare
vicino questo oggetto
ecco che appare
c'è un piccolo filamento
e all'inizio ha fatto pensare cosa fosse
una commenta pensate un po adesso
sappiamo invece che un getto
relativistico
né possiamo andare in profondità
all'origine di questo genere
era un immagine
agi che abbiamo tenuto sia la prima
immagine del di un buco nero
questo
questo è il 10 aprile questo è l'undici
aprile tutti i giornali del mondo hanno
messo in prima pagina questa immagine è
stato calcolato che nel giro di due
giorni 4 e 5 miliardi di persone ossia
una buona popolazione del nostro pianeta
attualmente chi vive a polo nord e sud
non l'ha vista in due giorni però
fondamentalmente tutti quanti l'hanno
vista ed è ovviamente questa è stata una
sorgente eccezionale di ispirazione per
tutti i social media
[Musica]
quello che cerchiamo di spiegare perché
crediamo che questa sia l'immagine di un
buco nero in primo luogo per un teorico
devo preoccuparmi di luce da quando la
materia cade vicino al buco nero e
questo è stato calcolato in maniera
sistematica e accurata risolvendo quelle
equazioni che vi ho mostrato e questa è
una tipica evoluzione di quello che
succede al plasma e care intorno al buco
del buco nero dimostrato con questa
sfera mostra una densità del toro di
materie di plasma che cade e mostra un
getto che è un getto di particelle ad
alta magnetizzazione con un forte campo
magnetico che viene espulso da da da
questo buco nero
se andiamo a vedere i dettagli di questo
disco di accrescimento vediamo che non è
uniforme e questo perché il processo di
accrescimento e un processo altamente
turbolento e che ci saranno le monete in
cui il buco nero accresce mangia un
sacco di materia altri momento in cui
buco nero a cresce di meno e questo crea
una variabilità nella nostra sorgente
per fortuna i tempi scala di questa
variabilità sono nell'ordine di decine
di ore ed è per questo che per noi
almeno m87 appare praticamente statico
questa è la posizione rispetto alla
quale pensiamo di hostare osservando
agli 87
adesso quello che dovete immaginare e di
mettervi degli occhiali ai raggi a
radio alle radiazioni radio e questo è
quel che vedreste vedesse essenzialmente
un anello di luce luce radio e una parte
di questo anello e più luminosa del
resto adesso
in realtà questo sembra un'immagine così
semplice soltanto perché siamo in una
configurazione molto fortunata di e di
orientamento
se noi andiamo a ruotare non solo sul
punto di vista quello che vedremo
qualcosa di molto più complesso e
spiegherò perché questa è l'immagine
così come verrebbe vista da dei
telescopi che è un'immagine molto più
confusa molto più diffusa è inserito
fossero quella che invece la nostra
immagine o sterrata adesso quello che
rende complesso fare un immagine e che
la luce vice un buco nero non si
comporta come abbiamo noi esperienze voi
state vedendo me d'accordo e non vedete
le mie spalle e questa è una cosa
abbastanza ovvia per voi però dietro un
buco dove c'è un buco nero questo non è
detto che sia così ma chiediamo di avere
un buco nero e di avere un disco che
stava mettendo luce e vogliamo vederla
una certa un certa inclinazione quello
che vedremo
e la prima parte del disco quella che è
diretta vedreste la mia la mia faccia e
il mio corpo nella parte più più diretta
ma un buco nero poi potete vedere anche
la parte dietro potreste ossia vedere la
parte posteriore della mia figura è
ancora più bizzarra perché vedere anche
la parte inferiore e quindi questa
immagine che sicuramente voi avete già
visto il film in the stella bene questa
altro non è un'immagine così così
complessa semplicemente perché fate
vedendo diverse immagini e diverse
rappresentazioni dei di un disco di
accrescimento sottile questo insegna a
noi una lezione importante se dovete
nascondervi non andate dietro un buco
nero perché non serve
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tutto dipende dall'inclinazione che a
seconda di come state guardando la
stessa immagine vi apparirà in maniera
diversa quando un esempio di come un
disco di accrescimento papa in maniera
diversa a seconda di come lo stiate
vedendo
quello che importante ricordare è che
c'è sempre una zona ma perché non stiamo
guardando il disco esattamente di faccia
c'è sempre una zona più luminosa degli
altri questo perché c'è una parte del
disco che viene verso di noi e la cui
luminosità e quindi amplificata un po
come la sirena di un'ambulanza che venga
verso di noi
suono più forte della sirena che si sta
allontanando si chiama effetto doppler
ed è amplificata ulteriormente in
relatività allora questa diventa più
difficile quello che abbiamo fatto noi e
fare tante simulazioni tante simulazioni
che ha ci consentono di coprire tutte le
possibili combinazioni in cui un buco
nero e i buchi neri possono apparire in
maniera diversa a possa essere stato
manifestato da queste simulazioni e
molte delle quali non fate le cose sono
state fatte a francoforte
abbiamo creato delle possibili scenari
cambiando le condizioni termodinamiche
degli elettroni che sono quelli che
consideriamo essere responsabili
dell'emissione di luce e da queste da
queste simulazioni a questi scenari
abbiamo poi creato una libreria
estremamente ricca di immagini abbiamo
creato sia 60 mila immagini sintetiche
che sono però soluzioni delle equazioni
e quindi sono clausi bili manifestazioni
di un buco nero supermassiccio adesso 60
mila immagini sintetiche e quattro
immagini effettuate raccolte attraverso
le osservazioni come si fa a capire qual
è quella giusta
bene questo è un tipico esempio di qui
possiamo utilizzare dei dei metodi di
intelligenza artificiale e a richiedere
il confronto tra la teoria e di
osservazioni per cercare di trovare
all'interno della teoria l'immagine
giusta
questo quindi un punto di vista
matematico è molto più complicato da
spiegare però a è facile a comprendere
con analogia di questo genere immaginate
che avete costruito un enorme libreria
di simulazioni
ognuna di queste è costata diversi mesi
di calcolo in super computer e come
vedete ognuna di queste è un po diversa
perché abbiamo cambiato leggermente le
proprietà termodinamiche degli elettroni
abbiamo cambiato la proprietà del buco
nero abbiamo cambiato se la luce venga
più dal disco dal getto così via
e quindi in questa maniera avete
prodotto 60 mila immagini allora è un
punto di vista logico concettuale quello
che abbiamo fatto
immaginate di essere allo stadio e che
in questo stadio ci siano 60 mila
persone e che ci sia una persona che voi
sospettate sia allo stadio ma di cui non
avete una certezza
avete una foto di questa persona però
questa foto è anche un po sfocata
ecco quello che il vostro software può
fare è andare a guardare tra e
confrontare le immagini che avete
prodotto dalle persone che sono lì con
l'immagine di riferimento e andare a
selezionare una distribuzione di
possibili
i candidati che vadano a vedere che
vadano a assomigliare alla persona che
andate cercando
ecco questo e non è quello che abbiamo
fatto ma è ideologicamente lo stesso che
abbiamo fatto e vi mostra come due cose
importanti il primo è che questi
algoritmi di intelligenza artificiale
sono estremamente artificiali e poco
intelligenti perché ad esempio è chiaro
che è una delle tre donne che è stata
selezionata non è la donna giusta
la seconda cosa che abbiamo imparato è
che nessuna delle donne selezionate e la
donna che andiamo cercando e questo è
possibile perché noi abbiamo
rappresentato teoricamente quella che è
una possibilità ma non è detto che sia
esattamente la realtà è la cosa più
importante è che ha appunto dobbiamo
accettare l'idea che la nostra
rappresentazione in realtà è solo
parziale però tutte sono donne già
questo ci dice che abbiamo il nostro
algoritmo sa riconoscere le donne questa
è un esempio di come alle osservazioni e
la teoria siano ben in accordo ed è per
questa ragione che in crediamo che
quello che abbiamo visto è la prima
immagine di un buco nero per
ricapitolare einstein già detto qualcosa
di molto rivoluzionario come funziona la
gravità c'è anche detto che questa
teoria che ha delle predizioni
stranissime come quelle dei buchi neri
sono sempre predette abbiamo mostrato
che al centro le galassie almeno di una
galassia ci sono c'è un buco nero
supermassiccio e crediamo che questo sia
vero per per tutte le galassie anche la
nostra è più importante abbiamo
trasformato un concetto teorico quello
del buco nero con dell'orizzonte gli
eventi in un concetto testabile e questo
è il primo passo in qualsiasi sforzo
scientifico grazie
[Musica]